[Music]
I'm a product manager and cloud
networking I work on a bunch of
different technologies including related
to cloud load balancing CDN and more
recently on service mesh and some of the
newer paradigms and one of the reasons
we put this panel together is there are
several talks where we talk about
products so we talk about solutions and
everywhere the theme is open and it's
hybrid in its enabling new businesses
nowhere have we really paused to really
say okay what is open mean especially it
might mean different things to different
set of people and then what are the
commonalities amongst all of those
people what are they trying to achieve
and so I thought I'd get four very
unique perspectives I'll let these folks
introduce themselves but let's see what
it what open means to them and then we
will also have a Q&A for 15 minutes in
the middle where you get a chance to ask
them questions so I'll call that out
once we get to that section but with
that I'd like to start with our first
panelist Anna and introduce yourself hi
I'm Anna berenberg and I'm a tech lead
for load balancing and one of the
product today was announced traffic
director I've been at Google 13 years
and projector is my partner in crime
they work together on a lot of products
hi I'm Kelsey Hightower kind of a
generalist these days that Google
focused mainly on containers and now
serve this stuff and have to deal with
these folks to get the networking the
way I want it and they're great too
hey everyone my name is Matt Klein I'm a
software engineer at lyft where I work
mostly on infrastructure and networking
I spend a lot of time these days working
on Network proxy called Envoy because
Holly I'm the CTO of Juniper Networks
before that I spent almost ten years at
Google building the production network
that a lot of the Google services run on
I'll probably just add some more because
they've been extremely modest so anna
drives a lot of cloud networking from
the inside she's one of the seven this
team
engineer females at Google Kelsey is the
face of kubernetes and cloud run and now
is still on when a whole bunch of things
Matt is the one who developed on void
lifts and Vikash is the one who
developed all of googles infrastructure
and now is doing the same at juniper so
I'm really excited to have them here I
wanted to start the question and you
know we can we can keep it free flowing
but I wanted to start off this panel
with a question which is we talk so
often about open and we talk about open
systems and does it really mean systems
does it mean api's does it mean
something else I want you to get your
perspective on what open means for you
and maybe we start from that end this
time so maybe because we can start with
you so open from my perspective you know
I see three layers of openness
it starts with open standards goes to
open API then it goes to open source and
from our perspective it's ultimately
something that the customers
increasingly want or need or demand from
the perspective of how do I get
innovation velocity how do I have
control on what I'm actually deploying
on my infrastructure without having you
know the supplier of the of the
technology having to do that and how do
I ensure security how do I get the
maximum number of eyes on on the product
that we're building so open cuts to the
layer but increasingly it's a business
need that's how I see it yeah that was a
fantastic answer probably would have
been pretty close to my own I think that
the thing that I would add is open to me
it also via open API is open source all
of those things it allows us to build
more powerful platforms so you know one
of the things that I think we've been
able to do with envoy is you know
because we have so many companies and
people adopting it we're seeing a cycle
of you know essentially vertical
applications that are starting to form
around that technology and I think
whereas historically we have competing
proprietary technologies you know that
tend to you know they focus their
efforts on a very singular fashion now
yes we can compete on vertical axes but
it allows us I think to actually make
more more progress I think for me I used
to say was kind of rooted in an open
source these days I guess care a little
bit less about that as long as I can
solve my own problems without waiting
for the vendor to do it for me if I can
get that in proprietary or open or open
source project I feel that gives me the
power to solve my own problems so I
think that's the key tenet for me
because there's some open source
projects where you can't actually extend
it to solve your own problems so that
doesn't necessarily fit the bill for me
3 for me is a Portability
interoperability and open standards all
of them because we want our customers to
write code once and run it everywhere as
you heard probably yesterday and today
about Anthes it's it's the same thing
right you can basically what we want we
want to build systems that hole
underneath horizontals where you can on
which you can build your business logic
one workload and because of portability
on underlying systems you can run it on
Prem and on multiple clouds also about
interoperability that means that control
plans need to talk to each other right
because just running it on each cloud
separately doesn't help you to make it
into a single deployment but you also
want to have so and how you can do it
you can do it all only with the open
standards because nobody wants a vendor
lock-in that is interesting and when I
when I take your definitions of open and
then I think back to a lot of the open
technologies each of you has been
involved in I think what would be really
fascinating for the audience because
it's fascinating for me is so just as an
example Mac you've been involved with
envoy and I was I used to always wonder
like why didn't you not like make a
startup out of it or you know you could
have like had this really fancy startup
and so in my mind the question and I'm
sure a lot of folks in the audience as
well is
open-source products that you've been
involved in what was the starting point
for them how did you think of them how
did they end up planning an open-source
and like what was your journey and what
do you think you would have done
differently in retrospect for those
projects and maybe we can start with you
Matt sure yeah so you know I think one
of the things that has made envoy so
popular is that it wasn't started as a
mm-hmm as a product that we were gonna
sell we developed it at lyft to solve
particular customer problems I've worked
in the networking space for you know
quite quite some years and you know I
had a feeling that maybe this thing
would be useful to folks outside I I did
not understand what would happen once we
open source it's been a really a really
incredible journey but that question of
starting a company and being open it's
one that's top of mind to me and I could
talk for a very long time about this
I'll stop myself but I think the key is
a lot of people right now are trying to
understand how to make money around open
source it's a very complicated topic and
I think there's two things that are
often at odds and those are about having
open technologies building a larger
community and very often when you're
trying to make money on something in a
singular fashion you know you might be
looking at business models like open
core where you're blocking features and
that tends to antagonize the larger
community so when people ask me about
hey Matt why didn't you go and start a
company
we can talk after but I don't think
envoy would be what it is today if I had
left and started a company we would not
have all three major cloud providers
using envoy we wouldn't have tens of
companies building products on top of
envoy because they would all be
competing with me and my company and
that does not make a larger and vibrant
community and I think I mean that's a
really interesting perspective and I
wanted to add in the cars perspective he
comes from a Wender and then you've had
your journey with open country land
which is now tungsten fabric and it's a
little bit different from what Matt
described so can you take us through
that and I mean what what what was
juniper
were you thinking as you took it through
that journey yeah so constant fabric
which originated in contrail five plus
years back the the the reason that it
was open sourced as open Cantrell in
those days was because the customers
actually asked juniper to do it and the
reasons were what I described before
that ultimately you know especially in
this space companies come companies go
when somebody's investing their core
infrastructure you know examples would
be very large carriers all of their
calls go over this infrastructure when
you're betting that mission-critical
applications on something you want to
ultimately control your own destiny one
or the other and having a codebase
that's that's open allows you to
ultimately control your own destiny if
you have to at that point it has come a
long way and and really you know what
what our vision is now with tungsten
fabric the reason that it changed from
open contract to tungsten fabric is I
believe that the new cloud stack is
built on open source I mean it's it
starts from you know Linux to KVM
to communities even before that
OpenStack openshift or missiles and you
know and so on and so forth like it's
it's built on open source this stack
needs a networking stack that doesn't
make assumption as to where your
workload is or which cloud it's running
on or who are it's deployed or whether
it's green field or brown field I mean
you know as much as all of us would love
all the applications to be container
eyes and service mesh best a large part
of the world still runs their
application on bare metal now how do you
get that deployment on the same network
stack that allows you to actually move
and migrate very quickly to the modern
ways of writing application but it'll
leave things behind and I saw that stack
was missing there were a lot of
networking stack that were designed for
very specific things but there isn't an
open source stack that actually allows
you to do all of this together and
frankly if you are trying to go into
multi cloud and if you're serious about
it
Multi cloud are the largest public
clouds but they're also open style
they're also VMware they're also bare
metal cloud that you have built right so
we saw the need and we saw the guy
and it was it is sort of the obvious
thing for us to sort of expand you know
the open source charter that open
control had introduction fabric and it
has been fabulous journey and then now
I'm taking you back to some of the early
days of Google and I know Kelsey you've
been heavily involved in kubernetes for
a really really long time like you in my
mind you are the face of kubernetes and
then now this cloud run and a bunch of
new things you're playing around with
when you think of kubernetes like I hear
you speak very passionately on the topic
like what is that journey and then what
were the tenets in mind where you said
oh it's going to solve this set of
problems really well and I also know
there are certain cases where you say do
not use kubernetes there so I'd actually
want to hear of it from the beginning so
what got you into kubernetes what was
the fascinating aspect of it the
community and so on so I think I think
early with kubernetes it's you know
Google's entry into the container place
where they have the most background and
expertise at that particular Check Point
right so Dockers dominate I'm at core OS
there's a start-up trying to build
Google's infrastructure for everyone
else and then Google comes along and
does exactly that so if you recognize
that if that was your mission and it's
now playing out and Google's very
inviting you know I was able to
contribute get things merged in and at
that particular time there's this kind
of friendly war the container wars lots
of us have scars from the container war
days and we were all trying to
capitalize on this ability to package
your app and run it in a very consistent
way but that wasn't necessary solve
across multiple machines and coup
Bernays added a lot of features to make
that as easy as possible ideally can
competing with things like docker swarm
Nomad all of these kind of easy-to-use
distributed computing things that just
try to make your environment look like
something like App Engine there was one
pivotal point where we understood that
the power of Coober days was not going
to just be that I remember we're doing
some empathy session internally and one
thing that was very clear that
kubernetes api and when we added CR DS
custom resource definitions to me that
was the biggest game changer kubernetes
is not just a container runtime that was
the first system that was built on top
of kubernetes so there was a phrase that
I said is
- bearnaise is a platform for building
platforms the thing about having a pis
and extensions of course you can extend
it but you can only do what the
interface provides hey here's a network
extension you can only do what the
interface provides in the kubernetes
world was we made it a very first class
thing to make custom extensions that had
nothing to do with the rest of the
platform you want to build a CI CD
system make a CR D and we would generate
all the client bindings Arabic will be
applied even to your custom extension so
we became a framework for building
extensions and that's very different
than just having a plug-in interface
over a limited framework and that was
key to me of letting people solve their
problems so to me it wasn't just because
kubernetes was open it was because it
was this open framework for you to solve
any poem that you wanted to regardless
if you got community consensus or not
and I think that was the pivotal point
when kubernetes took a life of its own
and coming to Ana so the reason I saved
Ana for the last is I have a lot of
visibility into some of their systems
she's built at Google I do wonder you
know oftentimes some we hear that oh but
we are not Google and I think a lot of
the paradigms that were built at Google
are not nestle meant only for Google and
a lot of the systems were born where we
wanted to abstract away the toil but
then still give you all of the benefits
so you can have the same benefits for
your services and so I wanted Anna to
just talk a little bit about you know
the systems you built for instance 12
years back and now you're building
systems out for cloud how do you see
that journey what kind of systems are
they how different are they today from
what you build twelve years back well I
started I started in 2006 and at a time
Google had couple data centers maybe 3/4
maybe a little more but we had a lot
balancer and the load balancer that was
in place was an square Lourdes balancer
and it was like falling in pieces so we
built totally new control plane Lord
balancing global that done wonderful
work and we organically grew it based on
the experiences with this big customers
we had which is a web search YouTube
Gmail each of which had very different
requirements but most of them turn into
requirements that are pretty much common
to everybody else they want to send data
as fast as possible they want to
minimize the round-trip time for for
overall traffic globally they want to
make sure they can run their workload as
cheap as possible so that means that the
one Lord balancer to distribute traffic
in a way that it will optimize overall
capacity and they want to make sure they
can control and debug things so there
are the administrative tools that build
into the traffic management and stuff so
the and we thought this is so Google
right and then we go into cloud and
guess what our customers wanted the same
the interesting thing though that we
learned a lot about it of over years and
the customers are pretty sophisticated
and they won't just write this this
moment exactly this that we built over
such a long time so it's not that Google
is very different it's we were a little
isolated and lived in this self kind of
bubble and the customers growing
customers needs growing very fast and
their requirements are outpacing at this
point internal Google requirements which
is interesting sounds great and then
just building on what baqar said one of
the interesting things he said is as
much as we want all of these
technologies to appear in our networks
and our deployments the world I mean
there is a lot of existing deployments
and we need to figure out how to get
these deployments to whatever is the end
state based on the goals of the
customers now one of the things I hear
about all of these technologies and
actually believe it but I also hear
about it is they will they are providing
a lot of ways to solve the challenges
that we face in a multi cloud world and
even when we look at cloud customers and
I'm sure as you look at your own
requirements you probably have a
deployment on Prem and then you are in
Google cloud and you're likely in other
cloud
as well and then it's extremely hard to
deploy to deploy and manage these so one
of the questions and I want to see what
their opinion is do you believe
fundamentally that these systems can
change can be game changers for enabling
you to deploy services manage them
seamlessly or is there is there a big
gap that needs to be filled before we
can say that like what is your take on
that and in any of you can start
depending on I think the biggest problem
we've seen this every time there's a new
technology that comes out there are some
people who buy what the vendors selling
they read the blog posts they kind of
copy and paste and retrofit not really
understanding the fundamentals there are
people who understand the fundamentals
and look at these new tools and evaluate
them on their ability to solve problems
in that fundamental space I think the
challenge is we have so many tools
coming out now the pace of those tools
and you get really confused if you don't
know what the fundamentals are at the
fundamental you could look at engine xh8
proxy and envoy that's doing very
basically the same thing and there's a
higher level fundamental around
configuration all right how do you
configure things most people are
familiar with configuring things via a
file and restarting something and you
look at envoy and say Oh Alice XDS
protocol to incrementally configure a
thing live that's a big transition for
most people so that's how I
fundamentally look at these things based
on fundamentals and say wow envoy is
really bringing something new to the
table fundamentally is routing packets
around but there's something different
than what you think in order to take
advantage of something like envoy you
have to understand the ability to
configure something that sits in the
network the way it is sets the stage for
things like sto and traffic director
without that understanding all this just
looks like noise and confusion and then
someone has to try to convince you and I
think unfortunately we've been trying to
do that through the sales motion and not
the engineering motion of saying this is
what these things actually are here's
what they do and it's okay if you want
to outsource that to someone but you can
understand what that technology is first
you can take advantage of it yeah you
know I think the the biggest problem
that I see is like like Kelsey said
there's so many technologies coming out
right now and there's this tension that
we have from the tools where and I see
this all the time with envoy where we
have a sex
people that come to envoy and they'll
say I don't understand this it's too
complicated I there's too many
configuration options I just don't even
know where to start and then we have
another set of people that come and
build absolutely incredible things that
blow my mind without ever talking to me
or anyone else on the project so we have
this tension clearly we have many
different users right from people that
want a prepackaged solution to people
that want an extensible solution to
build vertical things and I think the
key takeaway for me is that there there
is never going to be a one thing that
fits fits every possible end end case
and I think that we you know from the
infrastructure side we have to build
layered solutions right so there's going
to be something like kubernetes or like
envoy which is more of a platform and
then we might have vertical solutions on
top of that and then we might have pasts
or functional platforms that sit on top
and are more opinionated as we actually
get get further up the stack and I think
you know right now we're still in that
very early days of creating a lot of
tools and there's a lot of confused
people out there and I think we have to
iterate to find you know the right
layers of abstractions so that people
can tap in at the layer that's most
appropriate for them there's a lot of
Technology when new technology comes out
there's a large population in the tech
world that wants the new thing to work
the old way and this is what really
slows down some of these projects some
of the momentum you start adding a lot
of cruft of these projects that they
shouldn't be doing these things but in
an attempt to grow your user base
sometimes you will try to retrofit this
new thing that has bought into this new
paradigm to solve the old problems and
sometimes you just kind of draw the line
and say no that's not what this thing
does
even if it does cost market share or
different use cases so technology's just
like everybody else in the panel I'll
actually have a slightly different
perspective I spend a lot of time in in
my role with customers and I think as
technologists we often forget usability
we go after look how cool this thing is
with what it does but not how it
actually solves a customer's problem and
you know you sort of touched up on that
in the abstraction but it's actually
more than abstraction if if we don't
understand the current state of an
infrastructure of a customer and if we
show them the shining city on the hill
and we don't show them the steps to get
to the shining city on the hill and we
tell them by the way where you live
today
condemned house forget it it's not
reality it's not reality for any one of
us I have I'm yet to see and I can only
speak from Network I have built
infrastructure for a long time in Google
I speak to a lot of customers all the
time I mean to see a single instance of
a greenfield infrastructure doesn't
exist it's fantasy so if it is fantasy
then the reality is we've got to build
the steps if we don't build the steps in
technology it doesn't matter how cool
the shining city on the hill is it's
never going to be real and I think you
know I my view is that the technology
world has often ignored the steps and
that does not mean that you actually
drag your old broken house up to the
shining city but it means that you give
a way to get to the in state where you
are not layering yet another set of
tools here on the set of infrastructure
unfortunately you know one of the reason
for the explosion of the tools is
because we haven't quite solved the old
and we have anyone and ants we have
layered yet another eight another tool
right if I happen to have you know
infrastructure that must run on my 15
year old database because that's what I
have 100 million of my customers
information that no way I can migrate to
something else in next five years while
I still need to run that and if I tell
them that you're going to run that in
the way that we ran 15 years back which
was throwing people at it but you have
all these new shiny applications that is
fully automated in ten driven policy
operated and and this is a new way of
training your your workforce and
operators I don't think that's real
because I don't think anybody has money
to actually do it one of the beauty of
public cloud is that on
the infrastructure always changes the
stable API hide that I know for a fact
that UCP is seven years back is not what
gzip is today with infrastructure that
it has underneath but if somebody used
you know API is on GB most of those
areas are still the same I think when
the tools start doing that where it's
not really forgetting the migration
that's that's an important part for us
to solve we are definitely focusing a
lot on that with tungsten fabric because
you know most of the customers that we
see they absolutely won the world we're
a service mesh where security sort of
networking things security is an
application thing but they also run most
of their applications on bare metal
maybe on via means in some scenarios and
if I tell them that you know your policy
construct for service meshes this but in
the old way you're still configuring
firewall policies okay we haven't really
solved a problem for them so I actually
do believe that you know bridging the
gap between the old and the new is a
critically important component of the
technology and those that would do it
they'll win because the customers need
that to build intent driven
configuration system for service
management it turnout into success but
it only worked for 50 percent of
services work well for 35 it work
somewhat and it didn't work for 15 and
those 15 were probably the most
important ones the big they need every
little knob you you can even think of
and with that it understood that we need
everything we need the knobs as the
foundation and we need to have them
exposed
we need a simpler configuration on a top
- to help the the 35% and we do need
intense so I think we're at a point in
the cloud era where we still at the knob
level and I think when if we do the
knobs well then the verticals on the top
of it and in pain in turn based system
will grow next
I'm gonna have one thing so before
coming to go I've been liking your
position like trying to manage
infrastructure and maybe you share the
same opinion I don't from a provider we
have to try to support everyone when
you're at your own company you only care
kind of about your use case right like
I've been in cases where we burnt the
whole house down so we can have the new
one and it's painful not everyone can do
it but you can do it but as providers we
are kind of stuck in the situation where
we're trying to go out of a large market
share so we kind of have these kind of
Tuggle Wars internally on what the
features should should be and I think
there's just different people who are
concerned with different parts of that
when I looked at i'm wagons i looked at
as a clean start like there's a clean
start here to solve a very unique use
case I think docker came from the same
thing as a clean start to solve as a
unique use case and then once it gets
mass adoption I think you start to have
the ecosystem show up and there are
people who will help you adopt that
thing build a bridge technology but I
hope that we are free to continue to
build things that don't work in the old
world and then maybe someone will come
and bridge it but I don't want us to try
to figure out how to bridge everything
because I think it will stifle new ways
of doing things because we're always
constantly stuck with the 20yo of
decisions so I'm going to open it up to
audience before that I pulled out a
bunch of questions from the dory and
then also from LinkedIn and Twitter and
there are some really interesting
questions there was one for you Kelsey
what said how do you become good at so
many open source technologies if these
people are having probably some fan club
out there but they're having hard time
just getting their arms around
kubernetes and then you're already on to
cloud run on a bunch of different things
so how do you do that so 10 years ago I
came to the conclusion that there's
probably nothing new period just it is
there's data that comes and you do
something with the data and you put it
somewhere else
oh my sequel Oracle spanner doesn't
matter they all have their own little
protocol they're gonna store your data
in some format the bytes are the same I
know you want to say as cloud native or
new or it's old legacy it's all noise to
me there's a fundamentals so when I look
at the fundamentals bytes are moving
around
how do you want to move your bytes you
want to move it with with envoy envoy
has to move the same bytes in the same
way that everything else has its
to have a new interface is free to do
different performance things but at the
end of the day those bytes have to flow
in a certain set of directions that's it
so when I see new technology that comes
out for networking is very simple these
bytes need to go from point A to point B
what are you going to do with those
bytes and the same thing is true for
compute you're going to call instruction
sets on this kernel on this CPU you want
to do a going you want to do a Python
you want to do it with docker at the end
of the day you're just gonna make some
system calls so I don't know I never get
tripped up and confused with the noise I
just want to know how are you gonna do
the fundamental thing and that's how I
find bugs and that's how I work through
that's all it ever can be is the
fundamentals and then if you respect
that and you learn the fundamentals any
new technology that comes out you don't
have to ask one question how are you
implementing the fundamentals and then
that's how that's my secret to doing
that there's another question that so
I'm going I'm pulling this out of
LinkedIn and Twitter that came format
you developed a wonderful opens like a
data plane proxy why did you not build
out the control plane and open source
that's a that's a great question and
actually comes back to what we were
talking about before its envoy is a very
general technology and it's extensible
it has a bunch of API it's like I was
saying before we've seen it adopted in a
tremendous amount of use cases and like
Anna was saying if it didn't have all
the knobs as if it wasn't that base
piece of technology it would not have
been adopted in all these cases what you
find at lyft is that we have a control
plane based on envoy we built on voice
so the control plane has built up over
the last three or four years the control
planes a little embarrassing like I
would not I would not open so I would
not open source it it's a it's a
mishmash of like Python templating and
bash and go and I mean it's just you all
understand how these things go and and
my point is is that the thing we don't
expose all of the Envoy knobs to people
at lyft we have service manifests we
have a configuration generator we do all
these things so that people at lyft
only see a very tiny subset of the envoy
configuration but that also means that
the control plane at lift is very
specific to lift and we're not I I work
for a lift like I'm not building a
product and it just doesn't make sense
to invest in trying to clean up that
control plane in a way to open-source it
that doesn't mean that we have in open
source libraries there are libraries
that we support and on by open source
like go control plane and Java control
plane these are foundational libraries
but they're not complete solutions
because they depend on our jenkins and
our kubernetes and our legacy vm
infrastructure because we're not of
course not only on kubernetes so it's
really again just about those layered
abstractions and it just doesn't make
sense for us to invest in open sourcing
that control plane so there's another
question
thank you Matt and there's a question
for because so this person says as a
Twitter user the person says that you
built these massive systems at Google
and they've bent all of your talks and
they are like now as you are at juniper
which aspects of those or which
learnings are you utilizing at juniper
and what are you doing differently I
think the best way that I can describe
this is building system in systems in
Google it has certain expectations way
through your customers and those
customers are that the inside of Google
they're very savvy they're very tech
savvy so you want to expose all the
dobbs you want to make it highly
programmable you expect that there is a
sweet on the other side of the system
who is doing something very meaningful
with the system that is built-in in many
of the customers the level of program
ability that they can consume is
different and and it's a spectrum it's
not the same for everybody
for many usability is extremely
important and and so you know my my
mission in life really has been still
build open systems still build system
that is truly programmable build system
that has open API open data model but
also build usability on top where if
somebody wants to consume a truly modern
system they can without having to really
build you know the development team that
that Google has or can afford
and and that has been a learning you
know sort of talking to really spending
a lot of time with with customers and
seeing they all have the same need I
think Anna was making the point that
Google is not a bubble ultimately
everybody has need for similar
infrastructure whether they consume it
from cloud or whether they consume it
internally but making it usable for them
and making it usable without having to
make it proprietary there is a bit of a
tension in there but I think it's doable
and and that's that has been my goal and
then the last question is fine and then
we'll open up to one to do one or two
questions to the audience they say like
today people saw the traffic direct
announcement they know you're heavily
involved as you should out all of these
Google specific products should they use
it or should they be worried about
locking traffic director has opened an
interface to on voice or any accidents
compliant proxy so it's it's the way to
merge together all the value of
proposition as Google develop over this
15 years with the open sense with the
open interfaces and essentially
producing open system so let's say you
use traffic director today and tomorrow
you decided you don't want to use it you
build your own control plane there is
nothing that that locks you in into into
traffic director because you just switch
your point at which you sending this API
is and you get a different control plane
functionality with over the same API so
we hopeful that you are not going to
switch away because we're providing
amazing functionality but I'm not going
to be selling here but in general as
long as you have open interfaces there
is no vendor login so in my mind the
data plane needs to be universally open
source like envoy or
OTR PC that is without a proxy this this
basic transport needs to be open source
and then you have control planes that
are sitting on the top of it with the
open API is
also removing vendors lock-in and then
the cloud providers can compete on the
value proposition behind this API so I
did want the audience I want to give
them the chance to ask one or two
questions and then you can find them
after the talk because I don't want to
end with their perspective so if we can
have if you want to ask a question we
probably have only time for one or two
but just use one of the mics so
everybody can hear just a question for
you with regards to the Mongols
experiment with the server-side license
what do you think [ __ ] should have done
and what do you feel about the commuters
reaction to it well you know this is
actually what I was talking about before
look you know no one does anything in
this industry out of goodwill right I
mean let's just be honest we're all here
probably to make we're all we're all
here to make money
in some way some of us are selling
infrastructure some of us are building
businesses but very few of us if we're
really honest with ourselves are here
because you know this is the best thing
that we can be doing on Wednesday
afternoon so you know with that said if
you look around at people's motivations
they're trying to build a build a
business out of their software the
problem right now and I don't really
want to comment on [ __ ] or Redis just
because you know everyone has their as
their own business situation that
they're in but this is directly related
to what I was saying before about why I
didn't start my own company which is
there's a tension between locking down
open systems and software and trying to
charge people for those systems versus
building a welcoming larger community
which is extensible and then allows
everyone to succeed and this is very
subtle I've written a blog post on this
which you could check out if you want
but I think there are ways of building
viable vertical businesses on top
without alienating people on locking
down you know certain pieces
of the the software so what I would say
again without specifically calming and
commenting on particular companies I I
think there are ways that it can be done
but it's a very complicated problem so
we can probably take one more quick not
answering specifically to MongoDB again
for for because I don't know what their
business model specifically is I think
there is a misconception that
open-source is free it's not free some
the software developers have to make a
living by writing software somehow and
there has to be a business model somehow
for the software developers to make
money by to make a living
the the part that I found is very
important is to to to be very clear
about the business model that you have
around open source which sometimes is
not true and changing the business model
midcourse actually can be very
problematic for the community and I
think that's the problem the problem is
if we don't have the business model laid
out very clearly from day one
tungsten fabric has a business model of
open core where the stuff that is
open-source will always remain
open-source period it doesn't matter
whether a Juniper competition is
building a product without some
transition fabric it's going to remain
open source because that's the Charter
in Linux Foundation and I think you know
having that clarity of the business
model is important because otherwise
people build this mistaken assumption
that some open source is free and and
now you try to figure out how to
monetize it and that's that's the
problem some more questions so let's
take some more questions we can be
really tight with our answers I mean you
guys are here in person so we appreciate
it so go for it if you want to ask
questions just use one of the mics
though so everybody can hear the way I
see kubernetes is that it's a level
playing field for the way you build and
deploy containerized applications and
kubernetes is available both on Prem and
in all the public clouds is there an
answer
do we need an answer for network
security storage that's similar to
kubernetes or and do we have an answer
the thing is I think you're gonna need
someone
that level of experience willing to
build a system in a very similar way
that envoy did and kubernetes did and I
think that's gonna be very hard we saw
it we've get with source code or source
street management we saw it with Linux
so I think a lot of people have the
right motivations but you need all the
other factors and I think it's very rare
that you'll see envoy come from a place
that it came from I think it needs to
solve a real problem first for at least
one company first and put it out there
and if people think it can be generic
enough that a lot of people want to use
it I think that'll work out well we saw
this with like HTTP you know there's a
standard around it lots of people can
implement it but the problem with
networking it's a lot of cultural things
that are baked into how you layout your
network right there's different
architectures to mean networking is
closer to programming languages you can
decide what architecture you want your
network to take some info SEC teams
won't give out more than 10 IP addresses
they count them line oh no these private
IP is really gonna give you 10 it's like
what the hell are you doing with them
they're fake actually you can you can
make more of them
it's very cultural I have not seen you
know to me I think the networking
problem is that is so cultural for these
companies and if I gave you the best
networking tool like in kubernetes the
coach is gonna dictate how it gets used
that's the features are gonna ask for so
I think Cooper NACE is a little bit
easier because again you're just making
some system calls wrap up your code and
the container is gonna run it for you so
I don't know someone may try to do I
think obligates is very close but in
terms of how you layout architected
framework for your internal network I
don't know about that one any other
questions we can probably take one more
wise I want to put the panelists in the
hot spot so I can do that instead do it
do it ok so you know each of you like I
think you rightly pointed out that
different companies have different
motivations for doing all of this when I
look at each one of you there there are
several things as Kelsey pointed out we
have a very heavy-duty title for this
talk and so I wanted to put each of the
folks here on the hot seat to answer a
few questions like we spoke so much
about open systems and making the switch
from whatever your deployment is today
and then somehow migrating it to from
like whatever your end goal is so
bringing all of this to your brownfield
and so on and so forth but if you let's
say look two to three years ahead let's
say V of all of these open systems with
all of these paradigms what has it any
but like what kind of businesses do you
see what kind of problems solve what
kind of communities are we even going to
be talking about kubernetes and envoy
and service mesh and all of that two
three years down the line or will the
conversation be totally different and
maybe we can start with you because so I
think it the the very nature of
applications and and users are evolving
so it's a given that the infrastructure
is going to evolve I think that's one
thing that we know for sure everything
else is pretty pretty much I guess I I
do think that being open is a necessity
in the world that we live in and and the
reason being ultimately you know
sometimes I get this question of what is
cloud it's it's a set of stable API is
on an infrastructure the Bay P I hide
from you that's what it is and of course
the infrastructure evolves over time
it's true for everybody whether it's
public louder or private cloud it's it's
this it's the well defined abstractions
and API that that make it durable and
usable right so so I think the need for
open is coming from the fact that you
want a part of the infrastructure that
you can use for a long period of time
well the underlying scaffoldings will
change over time and you don't have to
reinvent your interest every single time
so so I think we've seen that if you if
you look back 20 years in how computer
was done you know the basic UNIX system
calls haven't changed that much the
underlying scaffoldings are
significantly changed I think my my view
and the thing that I typically tell
people is that you know all of us that
are sitting here building infrastructure
we're doing it to support application
developers building business logic like
that's the entire point I mean
infrastructures overhead there's no
point to it right I mean the way that
people make money is by writing business
logic so you know I think my goal and
this is not a three year out this is
more of a five to ten year out is that
I you know I think ultimately I do
believe in the quote serverless
paradigms and just by that I mean that
in the long run as Kelsey was saying you
want people to write code and store data
and talk to things that's it that's all
application developers care about they
don't care about container systems they
don't care about networking they don't
care about routing they don't care about
failover
and so I guess my view is that our goal
is to make it so that no one even cares
or knows about kubernetes they don't
care or know about envoy like envoy is a
transparent thing that provides
functionality and all people are doing
is the fundamentals and we're so far
away from that right now and that's what
excites me is that we have many years of
building better abstractions and better
systems so that the fundamentals just
they just get to people in a much
simpler fashion yeah so I think if you
look at like programming languages like
if you look at newer programming
languages I would even put Python in
that category and like golang they have
very extensive standard libraries like
go has this very busty HTTP server where
typically you don't need to front it
with anything and a lot of the libraries
that you see in the standard library
allow you to compose just software
that's ready to go on the network that
was goals goal if you think about this
from the platform perspective so
platforms are evolving from just these
bare metal machines Linux system D init
systems and now that we're in this like
kubernetes era serverless errors I think
kubernetes and envoy just become
standard libraries for platforms if
you're gonna build a platform to talk
about Matt's goal you're just gonna look
at these are standard libraries all
right I need something to handle this
network layer
I need something to handle the compute
layer you're gonna import those into
your stack and the thing that you build
on top will be that higher-level thing
that's what goes trying to do for you
you build programming logic you don't
think about SSL handshakes you don't
think about HTTP handshakes all you do
is import that library you write your
handler and you handle the requests
these things that we're working on is
also you can have that platform at top
so I think that's the best way to start
thinking about the future of these
things start at what do you want to do
what's the minimal require to do it and
all the things that are getting or your
way of the minimal requirement
that's the things that we probably need
to flush out and build but that's the
things that will underpin the long term
platform I agree with everything being
said here but I always say that in five
years network will disappear nobody
wants to program networking right and
find one developer who actually
interested in it so networking will
disappear all that container management
also and over here you'll have a
different panel you have a panel of
business developers who are going to be
talking to each other how to federate
how to make their vertical into
horizontals because at that time the
conversation will move a layer up right
and I'm not saying that we're going to
become a dinosaurs but by that time we
actually gonna solve we either solve the
problem or they're going to be where we
are today so we need to solve the
problem to become universal very much
horizontal across different environment
make workloads be the same no matter
where they run and basically solve the
problem that we discussed today good I
only have one thing the the time horizon
everyone thinks that this is five years
away I was at coop con and you know
everyone's talking about kubernetes and
service meshes and all these things and
there was a person there was a Google
how to shirt they were a customer and
they're like I am so glad we just use
App Engine eight years ago I don't care
about any of that and they run a real
business right it's not a fancy startup
they just don't care and they're like
why are people trying to rebuild App
Engine from scratch and so the thing is
some people have this reality I'm not
saying that it's gonna be reality for
everyone there are people who've had
this reality for a long time I think
most people need to just convince
themselves you're just trying to build
the same thing you just feel more
comfortable doing it from I think the
steps you this is your stepping stones
if you step back and I tell a lot of our
customers you really want to build App
Engine from scratch I'll show you how
but just know that's what you're doing
yes I think the reason for getting all
of these folks here and we are almost at
the end of the
because they wouldn't give us more time
but the reason for bringing all of these
folks is you know these conversations
are starting these are just the
beginnings of lot of conversations
around open systems open interfaces as
each one of us here goes and builds out
these technologies and open source even
within Google at juniper and so and so
forth and the whole goal was to get you
folks as well thinking about the open
interfaces also how whatever it is that
you build has a way for the community to
also benefit from that and also your own
business as well because everybody is in
it to create a business out of things or
to solve a particular problem and so one
of the things I highly encourage is to
also engage with these folks on Twitter
LinkedIn other forums and then keep the
conversations going so thank you for
coming and thanks to all of our
panelists please give them a big hand
[Applause]
[Music]